who are these people
they're you
they're me
they're european citizens
they came to strasbourg this morning to
make their voices heard on the future of
europe on the european union they want
to build
many of them are young people
and the future is in their hands
they have seized the opportunities set
out by the president of the european
commission ursula van der leyen who
called for a new push for european
democracy when she took office
the european parliament the council of
the european union and the european
commission jointly agreed to put
participatory democracy front and center
the conference on the future of europe
was born
against a tense international backdrop
with the kovid 19 pandemic and now the
war in ukraine
europeans must stick together
they must renew the dialogue with the
politicians who represent them
they must review their collective
priorities in every domain
without taboos
getting involved means helping to shape
the future of eu policies
we have to strengthen the role of our
role and we have to sit at the table
when big decisions are being brought
there is no time to lose
the world of tomorrow is a world of
empires it's a world of danger
we have seen it with ukraine
and in this world we need
to defend ourselves to organize
ourselves
[Music]
in march 2021 the european parliament
the portuguese presidency of the council
of the european union and the european
commission signed a joint declaration on
how this new space for debate with
citizens would be organized
a few days later an online platform in
24 languages was launched a place for
europeans to submit their ideas and
exchange in real time with fellow
citizens all over europe thanks to
electronic translation
a key tool for discovering about all
conference related events and above all
to define common expectations for what
the european union should be doing in
future
the conference on the future of europe
had officially begun
the conference is not a conference in
the classic sense of the word
it's a year-long democratic process at
all levels
individual and collective local regional
national
and european
the process indeed is based on three
main pillars and they are the most
innovative elements of the conference
the first pillar is the multilingual
digital platform
the second pillar of the conference
consists of 800 randomly selected
european citizens from across the 27
member states grouped into four european
panels of 200 citizens
these groups met several times online or
in person
in natalin florence dublin maastricht
and strasbourg between september 2021
and february 2022 their task to agree on
the recommendations they would like to
submit to the conference plenary
the conference plenary is the third
pillar
with about 450 members and the big
innovation
in this
plenary is the fact that we were mixing
political representatives with citizens
it gathers 108 citizens including 80
citizens acting as ambassadors for the
european citizens panels as well as 108
representatives of the national
parliaments 108 members of the european
parliament 54 council representatives or
two per member state and representatives
of the european commission and of
european consultative bodies organized
civil society and social partners
democracy
is very important uh part of our lives
so this conference is organized in order
to come closer to citizens and to fill
the gap which evidently exists between
policy makers and our citizens
three european commission vice
presidents were mobilized to respond
directly to citizens questions
dubravka schwitzer the co-chair of the
conference's executive board marash
chefchavich and vera eurova
each european citizens panel discussed
and debated in 24 languages key
priorities for european citizens
health climate change in the environment
migration education
jobs social justice or democracy itself
to name a few they have issued a series
of recommendations and in march and
april 2022 these recommendations were
presented in plenary in strasbourg and
turned into proposals proposals approved
in plenary taken together formed the
final report of the conference on the
future of europe they came with very
different views and very different ideas
but all of them came with a commitment
that really enriched the process
let's take a look at a few examples the
europeans working on the topics of a
stronger economy social justice and jobs
formulated concrete recommendations on
innovation the reinforcement of the
single market sustainable growth and the
demographic transition
meanwhile europeans focusing on
education culture youth and sport
proposed the creation of a european
education area with transnational
learning opportunities accessible to all
by 2025 as well as the reinforcement of
cultural exchanges
and together citizens looking into
issues related to the digital
transformation looked at ever more
pressing challenges like data protection
and the fight against disinformation
when we get to talk together on one
table on
different subjects we actually really
get to know each other it's a really
nice message that everyone is working
together in such a beautiful ways 27
states is not it's not easy to get to
work together topics as mental health
and sexual education are very important
to talk work it's not your life it's
only a part of it an amazing
demonstration of participatory democracy
and i think we should bring them into
the future more and more and get the
citizens involved
citizens who worked on european
democracy tackled big questions such as
how we could be more involved in the
preparation of european policies whilst
building closer links with our elected
representatives
they proposed regular citizens
assemblies
europe-wide referendums
the promotion of democratic civic
education and facilitating access to
information about the eu for everyone
europeans looking into climate change
and the environment didn't shy away from
ideas to save the planet touching on
topics as varied as food production
public transport and the crucial matter
of european energy supplies
and when it came to health participants
discussed mental health accessibility
and the price and quality of care for
everyone i get a better understanding of
how the eu works in general the people
are not here for the politicians
politicians are here for people
everybody can change the situation can
change the world it's important to to
make the citizens have a greater impact
on the decision making we didn't know
what was coming out of it but now we see
like the recommendations come to life
and that's really great one european
citizens panel explored the themes of
the eu's place in the world and
migration
they were united in their desire to see
europe reduce its dependence on industry
and energy from abroad and boost
cooperation on matters like defence and
diplomacy
and in terms of migration participants
put solidarity and the human dimension
first
they expressed support for efforts to
promote economic growth and opportunity
in so-called countries of origin
coupled with a truly common european
migration policy
we
want to make the life from migrants the
better we have to work hard and we have
to be better as a society as a union to
improve in total the conference on the
future of europe brought together more
than a million participants from across
the eu in some 6500 events national
citizens panels and european citizens
panels some eighteen thousand ideas
twenty two thousand comments seventy
three thousand endorsements from all
over europe fed into citizens
recommendations discussed in plenary in
strasbourg
there is a benchmark which is called
follow-up and feedback mechanism we are
gathering all their proposals and all
their recommendations we will cluster
them into the report
on the 9th of may 2022 the conference
draws to a close with the submission of
its proposals drawn from the citizens
recommendations into a final report to
the european parliament the council of
the european union and the european
commission but this isn't the end
it's the beginning of a new phase in the
policy-making process which reinforces
citizens voices at the heart of the
european union
it is only the beginning of our work if
you want to say something just say it
it's not about nations it's about europe
we all have to do it all together we are
strong democracy and what we have done
here will make us only stronger we are
the power
[Music]